why do you think that experiences of
transformation often employ the journey
motif in order to describe the nature of
the experience and that's because the
term ex tasses right implies transport
it implies crossing over it implies
moving from Who I am now to well become
and so it's interesting that so many
stories right like Eat Pray Love being a
key example employing this motif of the
journey to illustrate a character's path
towards healing right towards growth
towards apotheosis of course Joseph
Campbell the mythologist identified the
journey motif as the hero's journey
he says the mythology by which an
individual lives requires him to use
this hero's journey motif to impregnate
his life with a semblance of meaning and
signification we use this meta pattern
we use this as a set of codes and
symbols that actually give us reason for
being the biological advantage of
consciousness is that it allows us to
endow our lives with a narrative larger
grand narrative that marries someone
finite something finite to something
infinite and this through this
technology through this mythology
through this biological advantage that
we have grown to become the dominant
species on the planet there is like a
Darwinian reason for us having
consciousness and for us being creatures
that seek meaning through these journeys
of transformation through this journey
motif of transport of crossing over up
become
of evolving of transcending this is who
we are right
we are the storytelling animal we are
the journey errs we are the seekers
you